[Music]
bro I I gotta tell you man I I got I got
some Mark Harley stuff and I got some
Brendan stuff and I don't be able to go
through both of them today so which one
do you want to do today
um
none of them are time sensitive so it's
not they're not time sensitive
what do you think Virgie
I'm deferring to Virgie
that way you get all the blame don't
give me choices I don't [ __ ] All
Right Carly it is thanks guys
um you took too long
um there's another clip from that
podcast that he was on wait I thought
the Young Bucks weren't allowed to be on
any appearances until their suspension
was up yeah trust me I'm looking at the
numbers no one saw this
um oh that's not match Edison
um this is that other podcast he was on
but this is him dealing with the haters
okay so we do improv and it's almost so
difficult to get somebody that's just in
shape to be upset at all it's crazy no
it's not they get upset all the time
excuse me then you're batted first off
you do improv oh but second on purpose
what are you in three smile Island
what's what's the name of your group
yeah you went to San Francisco comedy
College too but he majored in improv
yeah he majored in improv yeah uh uh of
and it's he minored in baby proportions
almost so difficult to get somebody
that's just in shape to be upset at all
it's like the easiest thing in the world
anyone who's in shape and who is vain
those are the easiest people to make
upset about anything
it's crazy right right and I always talk
about yeah I talk about it then why are
you by the way in shape Mark Carly why
are you fighting with everybody on
Instagram then yeah because you seem
pretty upset you're so upset you got
your buddies [ __ ] tequila Instagram
band yeah and then the kid from the
blind side's there what's going on here
yeah now your buddy can't sell this
Trace commas that's exactly what it is
blitzki out at myself where I have these
little moments for like two commas out
of three commas no that's two commas
in the sauna today where I was like
borderline Curt with somebody but always
doing is going I just wasn't buying I
wasn't making him I wasn't going out of
my way to make him feel good and maybe
nine times out of ten I would but today
I was just like what was the sketch like
that was the extent of me and then I'm
like [ __ ] that was rude of me to do that
but because most of the time I can
manage if I'm not in a good mood that's
why I'm at the gym you know that's why I
wanted to make sure to go to the gym
before here because I'm like I want to
be in a good mood I want to get the
blood flowing oh yeah and and get a
little sweat going because that is so
integral to my well-being and so
integral to why integral I hate him
integral
I decided after you know I've taken
large swaths of time off of working out
but I get back into it because
mentally I feel better I like feeling
strong I like having this selfish do
people just like watch these dudes just
talk about their bodies
but yeah about their bodies
that it's a way to get off drugs too
right you supplement the drug use oh
yeah if you're on heroin just start
going to the gym bro yeah have you tried
jogging junkie yeah let me tell you guys
something man when I was down in the
dumps and I was [ __ ] way overboard
see what I what I did is I invested my
money she had a gym membership
and not more heroin and not more heroin
no I didn't buy any more heroin I've got
I didn't do CrossFit and Zumba honestly
I think at Planet Fitness now it's
heroin Fridays I think instead of pizza
so you're fine just go to Planet Fitness
no it's Fenton all Friday fentanyl
Friday
[Applause]
still addiction yeah I will say about
the haters though the burning shop thank
you here we go here we go here we go
again
haters I don't really care what Chris
Hardwick slash Rob Thomas has to say to
be honest with you here
up still haters be damned he lives a
one percent life he's not one percent
one percent would make him a billionaire
at the top half a percent life what do
you think burning Shop Raleigh makes 100
Grand a month from his comedy
no he doesn't no he doesn't he makes 100
I'm sure makes a lot of money 600 Grand
a month but it's not from his car that's
like his CBD and his all his little
products and his thick boy with three
C's t-shirts yeah not just not at stand
up beautiful house great cars hot wife
Jobs still living large and that's part
of being an Entertainer because Leo and
I have dealt with our Sheriff so shop
wants to be Rogan so bad
that he built his own rip-off little
Burger King kids club Rogan crew yes so
that now he could have a bunch of guys
hanging out talking about him sucking
his dick while he's not there yeah you
know I like the Brennan Shaw black pack
it's the best
hot wife British job still living large
and that's part of being an Entertainer
because Leo and I have dealt with our
Sheriff
[ __ ] haters who are you I don't know
with haters I didn't even know you
existed Leo and Danny
what hater maybe these guys are nice
guys I'm not judging them based off
their guest but I'm gonna say this that
guy has a lot of rings on his hands and
that's always weird unless it's a
wedding band right yeah unless you're
Johnny Depp knock it off yeah I mean I
don't know what that exactly you need
some leather oh yes leather bracelets oh
my God
the thing is though man it's still we
that's the price you pay because this is
a cooler job than humping a mop being a
janitor and yeah but Rogan humps stools
and he's a millionaire
and what you realize is a lot of people
all get sometimes I'll even have haters
do this because like a certain
percentages bro I swear I knew we got to
get a counter on the screen if we're
gonna watch these guys and just [ __ ]
just count every time they say haters
but well like if I'll engage in a
certain way they go you know what that
was like they'll realize it's a snap out
of it and that's just a small percentage
guys will realize that they're being a
dick but then double down so no no I
know I'm being a dick
because it's funny to me to make fun of
people like you who think you're smarter
than everybody else who think you're
stronger than everybody else your little
[ __ ] Hangers On do you understand me
you are Brendan shab's Stuttering John
and that is the worst thing you could
call a person
it's like a really small percentage will
realize and then tell you but it does
happen and then sometimes those guys
will be like yeah I really wanted to get
into acting screenwriting comedy so you
do see especially comedy or podcasting
probably the top two things where guys
in their head go I could do that I'm big
or shows bigger than you [ __ ] face
and I can't I mean look I don't wanna we
probably make more money than you too
Mark and not more than Brandon more than
you I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
he's got the rap career too oh that's
right so how many are you selling mix
mixtapes out of the back of your Prius
yeah I mean hey he is an entrepreneur
and kind of a business Jesus a genius
dude he [ __ ] uh he monetized
cross-dressing yeah that's a really good
point
funny in front of my friends yeah I
could hold a mic and be like I'm you
know so there is you are not a comic I
have never seen Mark Carly be funny on
purpose
the starting point too and you see it in
football too though we're like because
I'm a big football fan yeah are you
really are you wow that's such a unique
personality trait cool yeah yeah you
know what else I like merch steak and
sex I'm a little crazy whoa dude I'm a
little different don't tell everybody
all your little kinks yeah I love steak
and blow jobs
they should make a day about that yeah
yeah no they oh that'd be so cool bro
okay people
probably you look like you're probably a
football fan as well yeah but it looks
like he's from a GTA loading screen
[Laughter]
dude it is crazy how you have that
mustache on purpose huh bud is it ironic
or whatever I'm saying he looks like
Matt Jackson yeah Patrick Mahomes
[ __ ] jumper on and it was the MVP
Super Bowl channel are you comparing
Patrick Mahomes to your improv thing and
Mark Harley's uh [ __ ] mopping up for
Brendan
the next season he had one bad game and
I out of curiosity because we're in this
space where there is a lot of hate I was
like we're in this space
people
[ __ ] they're the worst you made
something that I love podcasting
immersion I've been doing for like
[ __ ] 14 years at this point and
you're turning it dead you're turning it
into a [ __ ]
[ __ ] West Coast therapy session you
this ain't fun no more because of people
like you because you're a little West
Coast therapy session and we're in this
space and you call it a pod instead of a
podcast
bro Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I wonder how to come up pretty odd no
Patrick on here scroll down you're
washed you suck they need to cut you
from the Kansas City Chiefs I understand
you're way overpaid when it goes to his
brother though I do a totally here to
hate going but I even appreciate it
going to Patrick Mahomes because you
know why Patrick Mahomes makes 500
million dollars over the course of his
career and he's world famous yeah
[ __ ] deal with it you and I sit here
and talking to Michael
but these guys are basically they're
right in what they're saying yeah you're
good hate it happens big deal but the
person who doesn't get that is the guy
who made a show called haters will say
and is fighting every single one of
Brendan's battles and [ __ ] [ __ ]
Instagram posting about what a [ __ ]
kalila is and Reddit posting that Theo
Von's a [ __ ] so it's not like he's
handling the haters well he's handling
them like an idiot because he's yeah one
would actually say he's spiraling about
it haters will say he's a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] around with these idiots yeah
and go up to San Francisco and go to
Mexico and have a great it's [ __ ] we
deserve to we have to work hard for that
yeah the haters it's part of the job and
there's no reason to get mad at him who
are you
let me look at your patreon because
you're in this space maybe this isn't
your main gig I don't know
387 people okay what are you talking
about
God damn it LA's people are ruining
podcasting bro well it just makes part
like you you can't get Patrick Mahomes
or Tom Brady oh my God neither one of
you are him
friends to do well so it's all good she
he was like Noel thinks that you are
really bothered by it and I use this
example of bothered by [ __ ] talking yes
because I'll write back and like you
might see me write four sentences to
somebody I like that the thing is and
then I'll post to my story right no like
and then he'll post it to his story
because haters don't bother him but he
has to make sure that he's showing
people own the haters hey Mark why don't
you post on your stories that we think
you look like the gayest lion that's
ever lived how about that why don't you
post on your stories that you went to a
San Francisco comedy College which is
basically wedged in between a DMV and
another DMV
so I mean and that's because it couldn't
get to your joining spaces
you're in the DMV part where the where
the 15 year olds have to take their
driving test
do you understand
yeah Jesus Christ was this the comedy
college no this is the DMV
um as you know do you know how quickly I
can formulate three sentences it's like
it's like a knee-jerk reaction the idea
that yeah I would hope that everybody
could quickly form three sentences
he's saying something that somebody who
doesn't have brain damage should be able
to do easily yeah well gee [ __ ] you
know how easy I can color inside of the
lines I'm sorry Mark is your Baseline
that people have a hard time forming
three sentences is that where you think
normal people are
Mark the fact that you bragged about
forming three sentences quickly is
insane to me
one day ten sentences I did it bro
you're [ __ ] Mania I swear to God how
did you do it do you have any like
you're getting it too you know after my
third sentence I was in a Zone after my
turn yeah I gotta after my third
sentence I was in a Zone I was in a Zone
oh so you had this you had what they
call a hot hand yeah yeah yeah I had a
what they call a talker's eye
they call me Roy silver tongue Lopez
because like 10 sentences no problem
he's a regular Firebrand oh my God
who wishes he strings together five
dollar words into a 25 sentence he
should be fire Bland because you
constantly if you respond you'd
constantly get accused of being angry
and I go I do you understand how
non-articulate if I was truly angry the
things that would be coming out of my
mouth and the sense that I wouldn't be
making I mean you're with I'm sorry sir
again these are this shows you how
stupid he really is do you think you
can't be angry and be articulate if
that's true we don't have a show yeah
you kidding me I wouldn't be able to
function if I if I couldn't speak while
being angry I'd be [ __ ] yeah I'd be
like the Hulk not being able to become
the Hulk when he's angry yeah no exactly
Mark I'm sorry are you so roided out on
[ __ ] Deca and Tess that your your
hormone levels are so high that you
can't be angry and be articulate
seriously
dude this guy it shows you because he no
matter how smart he thinks he is he lets
these things slip all the time about
where he's at normally
witnessing at most mild irritation but
it's hard for people to wrap their minds
around not mild irritation when your
entire show is called haters will say
and it's like you know somebody doing
stand-up comedy and like your only
experiences of it like you've thought
about doing it in major heart race and
it's like well this guy you know Crystal
Lee has been on stage 8 000 times do you
think he's nervous whatever two times no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no go back I got it I I already I
already went back I already went back I
already have peanuts I already went back
but like he just said it the way a black
chick says period yeah but it's hard for
people to wrap their minds around it's
like you know somebody doing stand-up
comedy and like your only experiences of
it like you've thought about doing it in
major heart race and it's like well this
guy you know Crystal Lee has been on
stage 8 000 times 8 000 times
rotation sorry I gotta hear it again
it's hard for me to wrap their minds
around it's like you know somebody doing
stand-up comedy and like your only
experiences of it like you've thought
about doing it in a major heart race and
it's like well this guy you know Krista
Lee has been on stage 8 000 times do you
think he's nervous about that or
whatever no because it's not a Chuck E
cheese and he's on a date I mean I get
it
so when I talk [ __ ] I use this analogy
of not a knowledge in a state inadequate
you don't talk [ __ ] I've seen you try to
talk [ __ ] and all you did was [ __ ]
make Brennan lose his whiskey brand on
Instagram
but if me go getting up in the middle of
the night I'll see a notification
fire off a [ __ ] talk while I'm peeing
and then go back to sleep because it
doesn't stress me out but you sit when
you pee
because I I don't know Marsha have you
ever said the text while standing and
peeing that seems like a weird way to
send a text right I feel like that I
could just wait yeah I'd be afraid I'm
gonna drop my phone in the toilet yeah
yeah but that's a real thing because
also you're kind of addicted to your
[ __ ] phone buddy if you get at the
middle of the line you have to go you
grab your phone to take a leak just take
a leak and go back to sleep yeah that's
what I do it just doesn't interference
with your REM sleep or maybe not one
thing that's I mean and I forget about
it too because as you're saying that
there's a lot going on there but but but
uh mark one thing I want to say is that
because I just think about how best to
deal with haters too and you mentioned
earlier they won't stop talking about
the haters bro you guys talk for
somebody who doesn't care about haters
for you talk about the haters a [ __ ]
lot mm-hmm
the mindset and how bad that is one of
the reasons the victim mindset is so bad
is because your mental picture is I'm a
loser there's no hope therefore I'm not
going to try hard yeah yeah but see Mark
Harley says I'm a loser and there's no
hope and he goes if I keep lifting
enough weights that feeling will go away
but instead now you're just big and sad
[Laughter]
now you're big and sad and that's even
worse than being normal more of you now
to be said yeah
exactly why do you do it to yourself
[ __ ] feet
and then basically the foundation of all
self-help and personal development books
are your mental picture you read
self-help and personal development books
La comics
they do really suck this is the kind of
[ __ ] that merged back in the day back
When We Were Young Guns doing this
[ __ ] podcast Young Bucks Young Guns
yeah back when we were [ __ ] young
go-hearts young go-hards doing this the
only people people that would act like
this on a podcast were like all women
shows I'm being serious it's not like
try me [ __ ] shouldn't I'm remember merch
like back in the day every other podcast
that we listened to was guys trying to
be funny and you know some of them
failing some of them not and whenever
you would see some of this drama like
self-help book and therapists it was
like listening to like I don't know two
broads yameron about lust and love or
whatever
not to get specific
needs to be very positive and very well
defined the reason I don't seek out read
and respond to negative comments is
because you have no fans and nobody's
really saying anything to you I mean I
wouldn't seek out any comments and no
one gave them to me either you know what
I mean I'm not seeking them out what are
you seeking out bud
I don't even know who you are man I'll
be honest with you might be a nice guy
and the guy on the right I'm gonna try
to believe against all my instincts that
somebody wearing shorts that shirt a
shirt like that leather bracelets rings
and that it just looks like a [ __ ]
you're not you can't be big gay lion but
you could be mini gay ocelot and I don't
like it
I just I I don't like the fact that you
know Kenny Omega and Nick Jackson are
sitting at home and this guy thinks he
can just [ __ ] break his suspension
and you know what this guy's thinking
that it's 3am and he must be lonely
Sinbad thanks Rob Thomas
[ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] love that episode